Professor Langdon
Hammer: On Monday I left off
talking about this--what shall
we call it--exciting and
dramatic ambivalence that one
finds in the early Eliot that
expresses itself in his
relationship to literary
tradition;
where on the one hand,
he presents himself as a truly
subversive and aggressive
entrant into literary tradition,
someone who's really going to
shake it up and transform it;
and on the other hand,
as someone who is a
traditionalist,
who is going to speak with
deference and seek – the word
he uses is "conformity"--with
the past.
Somehow, both these things are
going on at the same time and in
relationship to each other.
And "Prufrock" itself is a
poem, I think,
preoccupied with this kind of
ambivalence that I'm describing.
On the one hand,
it is a poem that introduces us
to a speaker who lacks will and
who seems timorous and timid and
who hesitates before action.
On the other hand,
he is a speaker who says to us,
"There will be time to murder
and create,"
as if creating and murdering
were, in fact,
in some relation and might go
on at the same time.
And in fact,
if one does have some sense of
creativity as involving a kind
of aggression,
or even murderousness,
one might hesitate before it,
right?
These psychological dimensions
that I'm describing have,
well, Freudian and Oedipal
dimensions that I think are
readily apparent.
How is it possible for Eliot to
claim the authority of past
literature without,
at the same time,
either destroying it or utterly
submitting himself to it?
This problem expresses,
I think, Eliot's double
relation to the past and is
expressed,
as I was suggesting last time,
in the ambiguous use of
quotation that seems to hover
between some kind of deferential
honoring of the literature of
the past and something much more
provocative and often parodic.
And you can think of the many
different texts that "Prufrock"
alludes to and borrows,
only some of which are traced
in your footnotes.
In fact, there's a great many
more than you find in your
footnotes.
There are quotations from
Marvell, from the Bible,
from Dante, from Twelfth
Night.
Well, there's that opening
quotation from Dante,
from the Gospels,
too.
Prufrock's world-weariness,
you know, "For I have known
them all already,
known them all,"
as understood in the poetic
context, this seems to,
well, express his sense of
belatedness and of
the--everything having in some
sense been done already.
In, again, Freudian or Oedipal
terms, terms that Harold Bloom
would develop as a reader of
Eliot in his own criticism very
influentially,
you can put the problem this
way: how can Eliot come to write
in the father's place without
killing him or being overwhelmed
by him?
In his confrontation with the
past, neither he,
Eliot, nor the past must be
destroyed, or the game's over.
Eliot thereby swerves,
you could say,
alternatively from each of
these unacceptable alternatives.
And that kind of
back-and-forth-ness you feel in
Prufrock's divagations and
wanderings.
You see it throughout Eliot's
early career in his funny
mixture of avant-gardism and
traditionalism because he's both
those things.
I've been describing this in
psychological terms.
We could also think about it in
social terms,
and I think it's important to
do so.
This Oedipal drama that I'm
describing is also a social
drama in important ways.
Here is a question:
how does a young American –
because that's what he was –
go and win a place in English
literary culture,
insert himself in a tradition
that includes Shakespeare,
Milton, Tennyson,
and Wordsworth;
insert himself not only as a
member of that tradition but as
a central explainer of it and
tastemaker, which is in fact
what Eliot would become?
Last time I pointed out that
Eliot's expatriation,
his going from the U.S.
to London, was a rejection not
only of America and
American-ness,
but in particular a rejection
of his father,
who died while he was abroad;
and there was a certain amount
of question about whether Eliot
would return in time to see his
father before he died.
In a very short time in London,
Eliot becomes more English than
the English.
It's a strange and marvelous,
fascinating development.
He learns or creates a certain
style of English-ness that he
then goes on to teach to the
English themselves.
This is what Williams –
William Carlos Williams – and,
in fact, other American writers
despised about Eliot,
that he was the--not just the
Anglophile that he was,
but the true English authority
that he became.
He made himself,
without any previous standing,
any connections really in
London or in English culture--he
made himself a central cultural
authority,
which became in a very short
time almost synonymous with
tradition itself.
This is an amazing and
remarkable achievement and an
important cultural event.
The thing is that the tradition
that Eliot expounded was
something to a large degree he
invented.
Eliot is not,
as he is often seen,
I think, the defender of a
social order that was passing
away.
And sometimes Yeats represents
himself that way.
Rather, Eliot is the
representative of a new class,
a new class opposing itself to
the traditional social authority
of money and of blood,
aristocracy,
that makes its claim for social
authority on the basis of
knowledge,
technical knowledge and
expertise above all:
a kind of professional class
into which you,
too, are being educated largely
through the modern university.
Eliot's tradition,
that I'm saying he invented or
created, described,
defined--he made it out of the
education he had received at
Harvard.
And he also,
importantly,
made it outside of the
classroom, in part in the school
of Ezra Pound who,
you might remember from last
week, specifically also when he
expatriates, leaves behind the
vulgo,
the people, and sees himself as
entering into some kind of
timeless tradition that he
identifies – Pound does –
with the "spirits of irony and
destiny."
That's his phrase to describe
the great writers of the past.
Eliot also enters this kind of
semi-imaginary community of
tradition.
Eliot's sense of tradition is
established in part through his
quotations and allusions in his
poetry,
in part and importantly,
and I'll talk more about it
today, through his criticism.
This kind of tradition with
which Eliot allies himself,
you could say bankrolls
everything he does,
legitimizes and authorizes,
gives sanction and precedent to
what was Eliot's strange new
poetry.
Frost, you remember,
as he says, "goes to market" so
he could stand on his own two
feet.
Well, Eliot went to tradition
to establish his autonomy.
And tradition allows him to,
well, to stand apart both from
the genteel audiences that Pound
resisted,
that Frost in certain ways
courted, and also allows Eliot
to stand apart from the
avant-garde,
which he has a kind of
ambiguous relationship to;
allows him to stand apart,
you could say,
from the audiences of both a
magazine like The
Atlantic or Harper's
on the one hand,
and on the other hand a
magazine like the Little
Review or Blast even,
where he did appear,
or Broom --some of those
magazines I showed you in the
first week.
Eliot's own magazine,
which becomes an important
vehicle for his work and his
ideas and his authority and his
presence in literary
culture--and you can go back and
look at its cover in the images
for the first week.
His magazine was The
Criterion,
a magazine that had a kind of
semi-official look and
represents the fantasy of,
I think, a kind of
institutional and universal
authority.
Well, how do you go about
inventing tradition?
In order to do so,
Eliot had to demonstrate that
the received existing tradition
was a false one.
"The Metaphysical Poets" is the
great and peculiar,
in many ways,
essay, in which Eliot
undertakes this work in a very
influential form.
And I'd like to look at it with
you for a few minutes.
It starts on page 950 at the
back of your book and goes to
page 953.
This was a book review.
This was one of the great book
reviews in the history of
English criticism.
Eliot was reviewing an
anthology of the metaphysical
poets.
That is, poets of wit,
in particular of the--largely
of the seventeenth century,
including poets like Donne,
whose reputation Eliot did a
great deal to establish in this
century.
In the process of reviewing
this anthology,
Eliot comes up with a whole
alternative theory or
alternative history of English
literature and certain key
poetic propositions and
statements.
Let me just emphasize a few of
them for you.
You'll see how the account of
literary history and Eliot's own
ideas of poetics are all kind of
mixed up.
And so you have to consider
them together.
On page 951,
he has just quoted Donne,
and then he's quoted Tennyson.
And the idea is that Donne is
good, Tennyson is bad.
Now, he will continue and say:
The difference is not a
simple difference of degree
between poets.
It is something which had
happened to the mind of England
between the time of Dunn or Lord
Herbert of Cherbury and the time
of Tennyson and Browning;
it is the difference between
the intellectual poet [that's a
good kind of poet]
and the reflective poet [bad].
Tennyson and Browning are
poets, and they think;
but they do not feel their
thought as immediately as the
odour of a rose.
A thought to Donne was an
experience;
it modified his sensibility.
[Evidently, he felt his thought
as immediately,
as sensually,
as the odor of a rose.]
When a poet's mind is perfectly
equipped for its work,
it is constantly amalgamating
disparate experience;
the ordinary man's experience
is chaotic, irregular,
fragmentary.
[Maybe quite a bit like
Prufrock's, you would think.]
The latter falls in love,
or reads Spinoza,
and these two experiences have
nothing to do with each other,
or with the noise of the
typewriter or the smell of
cooking;
in the mind of the poet,
however, these experiences are
constantly forming new
wholes.
Well, you can see there a
little recipe for an Auden poem,
excuse me – well,
maybe for an Auden poem too –
for an Eliot poem.
It's a poem about falling in
love, reading Spinoza and
listening to the typewriter
while somebody cooks something.
We may express the
differences by the following
theory [And note that "we":
you know,
Eliot has this "we" that you
just have to bow before when he
uses it, or join him,
I guess]: The poets of the
seventeenth century,
the successors of the
dramatists of the sixteenth,
possessed a mechanism of
sensibility, which could devour
[and that's an interesting word]
any kind of experience.
They are simple,
artificial, difficult,
or fantastic,
as their predecessors were;
no less nor more than Dante….
In the seventeenth century
[however]
a dissociation of sensibility
set in, from which we have never
recovered [And this--what does
he mean?
He means thought and feeling
have somehow come apart];
and this dissociation,
as is natural,
was aggravated by the influence
of the two most powerful poets
of the century,
Milton and Dryden.
And then he goes on to complain
about Milton and Dryden and then
follow the Romantic inheritance
of Milton and Dryden in the next
paragraph.
He says:
The sentimental age began
early in the eighteenth century,
and continued.
[Wouldn't you like,
in your own essays,
to be able to give this kind of
rapid-fire summary of literary
history?]
The poets revolted against the
ratiocinative,
the descriptive;
they thought and felt by fits,
unbalanced;
they reflected.
In one or two passages of
Shelley's Triumph of
Life, in the second
Hyperion [of Keats]
there are traces of a struggle
toward unification of
sensibility.
But Keats and Shelley died,
and Tennyson and Browning
ruminated.
It's amazing literary criticism.
Well, here is quite an
extraordinary account of English
literary history.
Eliot is proposing this.
It's quite a strange and
interesting claim,
which for a long time,
I might add,
really was persuasive and
became a kind of orthodoxy among
readers of English poetry.
And that is:
that the metaphysical poets,
for centuries viewed as an
anomaly in the history of
English poetry because of their
extreme intellectuality,
their poetry of wit,
that this anomaly in English
literary tradition actually
represents central values in
literature that were lost
through what Eliot views as an
eccentric and aberrant
tradition,
which is, in fact,
that which descends from Milton
and runs through the Romantics
and Victorians.
Samuel Johnson in the
eighteenth century influentially
complained of the metaphysical
poets that they "yoked the most
heterogeneous ideas together by
violence" – this is Johnson's
phrase.
In other words,
they were forced and willful
and they put things together in
a kind of violent and artificial
way.
Eliot is flipping that around.
And he says,
only the metaphysical poets
united thought and feeling.
And it's these other poets that
have been deficient and marginal
to the main mission of English
poetry,
and that they are symptomatic
of some derangement in the mind
of England that he calls a
"dissociation of sensibility,"
which somehow set in in the
seventeenth century or so.
All of this,
this whole sort of account of
how English history,
English literary history,
developed – all of this in
this essay suddenly,
without any preparation,
turns into a defense of modern
poetry,
or you might say a defense of
Eliot's poetry.
He says, without,
as I say, really any
preparation on the bottom of
page 952:
It is not a permanent
necessity that poets should be
interested in philosophy [as I
was, or as I am],
or in any other subject.
We [and there's that "we"
again]
can only say that it appears
likely that poets in our
civilization,
as it exists at present,
must be difficult.
Our civilization [he continues]
comprehends great variety and
complexity, and this variety and
complexity,
playing upon a refined
sensibility [such as mine],
must produce various and
complex results.
The poet [and now he's telling
us what poets must do]
must become more and more
comprehensive,
more allusive,
more indirect,
in order to force,
to dislocate if necessary,
language into his meaning.
And then he will go on to quote
French poetry,
modern French poetry,
to demonstrate,
as he feels it,
the continuity between modern
verse and the metaphysicals.
Well, here, Eliot is saying,
first of all,
that the character of modern
poetry--and again,
for which we must read,
his poetry--is simply a
reflection of the forces playing
upon it,
the variety and complexity of
our civilization.
In that formulation,
the poet seems almost passive,
doesn't he?
Passive and like a kind of
receptor that is naturally and
necessarily producing the kind
of strange poetry that Eliot
writes.
Then, before that idea has
really sunk in,
Eliot gives us another view of
what the poet is doing.
The poet is not in fact
passive, but rather,
he is forcing,
he is dislocating language into
his meaning.
And it's such an odd phrase,
to "dislocate language" into
your meaning.
It suggests that the poet is
not merely producing language,
but moving it from one place to
another.
The question that we might ask,
though, standing back,
of the metaphysicals is a
question that we could ask of
Eliot's poetry.
That is, does this poetry that
Eliot's talking about put things
together or take them apart?
Does it represent some kind of
synthesis, or rather,
some kind of violent
derangement?
Is it a mirror of a various and
complex civilization?
Is it in that sense mimetic,
realist?
Or is it rather
expressionistic,
willful, a kind of subjective
and highly personal expression
in which the poet is
purposefully,
actively dislocating and
deforming language?
Is it in this sense a poetry
that is a kind of necessary and
inevitable expression of the
age?
Or is it perverse and
eccentric: an arbitrary
assertion of authorial will?
These are questions that
Eliot's own work,
as I say, raises and that are
part of the history of his
reception.
Eliot, in his account of the
metaphysicals and then in his
defense of his own kind of
poetry,
seems, I think,
to equivocate to a degree
between these alternatives.
Equivocation is,
again, the key rhetoric of
"Prufrock" and of Eliot's early
poetry,
of Prufrock's temporizing and
his delays and his going back
and forth.
Let me say just a couple more
things about "Prufrock" in the
light of what I've just been
quoting for you from "The
Metaphysical Poets."
"Prufrock" has a kind of
ambiguous relation to the past,
and specifically to the past of
English Romanticism.
The poem is simultaneously a
deconstruction and critique of
the Romantic ideals and values
of originality,
of expressiveness,
and it is also a highly
original and expressive
reworking of those ideals.
It's a kind of anti-Romantic
poem that is an extension of
Romanticism.
Unlike the conventional love
song, this one comes from the
head rather than the heart or,
you could say,
really from that opening
quotation from Dante on,
it comes from,
comes out of many other texts.
I think that there's a kind of
suggestion or implication in the
poem that what people claim is
original and primary is always
in some sense already scripted.
That consciousness,
the way our minds work,
is linguistic:
that we think and feel through
language,
with language,
and through a kind of collage
network of verbal associations
made out of texts and phrases
from not only literary
tradition,
of course, but the whole
spectrum of everyday life.
Original speech,
heroic action,
the will, unmediated desire:
these ideals are all rejected
in "Prufrock";
parodied;
subjected to irony,
discontinuity.
They're seen as Romantic
illusions, clichés.
The poem is not merely a parody
of them;
or, maybe through parody it
does something else.
It is, of course,
in its own way,
quite as daring and disturbing
a poem, disturbing to the
universe of poetry at least,
as any modern poem.
And I think you can see it as,
in effect, a new kind of love
song, one in which the
withdrawing of desire from an
object – our consciousness of
our own desires – subjects
them to reflection but at the
same time sustains them and
re-voices them through
reflection.
You could say that what the
poem does is to intellectualize
longing.
And, behind that,
it makes of the modern skeptic
and intellectual a new kind of
Romantic hero.
What does Prufrock want,
ultimately?
What does he mean when he says,
"No, that's not what I meant at
all?"
Well, it's hard to say exactly.
But the poem does conclude,
and as it does it gives us a
kind of answer,
I think.
Why don't we look at the end of
it?
That's on page 466.
I grow old. . .
I shall wear the bottoms of my
trousers rolled.
Shall I part my hair behind?
Do I dare to eat a peach?
I shall wear white flannel
trousers, and walk upon the
beach.
I have heard the mermaids
singing, each to each.
You see, here,
Prufrock has moved into these
rhyming tercets.
He says quite simply and
definitively:
I do not think that they
will sing to me.
I have seen them riding seaward
on the waves
Combing the white hair of the
waves blown back
When the wind blows the water
white and black.
And as he describes this,
there is kind of heightening of
conventional lyric language with
that alliteration and with those
images:
We have lingered in the
chambers of the sea
By sea-girls wreathed with
seaweed red and brown
Till human voices wake us,
and we drown.
It's hard to interpret,
I think, the end of this poem
precisely.
I think that Prufrock has
really no clarified,
no specified desire,
except maybe to hear the
mermaids.
"I do not think that they will
sing to me": "I want them to,"
he seems to be saying.
In a sense, I think,
you could say he wants Romantic
singing.
He wants to hear it.
Perhaps he wants to be able to
join in it himself,
which is a wish for lyric
inspiration, isn't it?
He doesn't want to make love to
these mermaids.
He wants to hear them.
He wants to linger with them,
to have access to their
element, and to that extent to
be among them and even like
them.
It is a wish for,
specifically,
freedom from human voices,
which I take to be the endless,
overheard inner voices in which
the quoted, repetitive speech
that makes up his consciousness
consists.
In this sense,
it's a wish for a renewal of
Romantic enchantment,
which he knows is impossible,
and which he also knows,
I think, is a wish as old as
Keats's "Ode to a Nightingale."
And this is a poem,
ultimately, very much in that
Keatsian tradition.
The Waste Land:
let's begin at the end.
Let's begin at the end,
on page 486.
The Waste Land is a poem
that comes in five parts.
The fifth section,
I think, it's the longest,
is called "What the Thunder
Said."
It reaches a kind of climax
when the poem renders the voice
of the thunder.
In the landscape of The
Waste Land,
we are waiting for water.
We're waiting for everything
that water would represent.
And thunder promises that
water, and it also,
importantly,
represents a kind of speech:
a speech that comes out of
nature,
something that the thunder
says, has all kinds of
mythological resonance.
You might even view it as the
voice of myth itself,
here able to be given a voice
and a hearing in the poem.
What the thunder says, is "Da."
Da: a primary syllable.
There is a note explaining
this, coming to us from your
editor and from Eliot.
It is the first phoneme that
becomes part of the instruction,
the series of instructions
"Datta,"
"Dayadhvam,"
"Damyata," translated as
"Give," "Sympathize," "Control."
When the thunder speaks,
this is what it has to say.
It gives us these instructions.
On page 486,
I'll just focus on one of these
imperatives:
Da
Dayadhvam:
I have heard the key
Turn in the door once and turn
once only
We think of the key,
each in his prison
Thinking of the key,
each confirms a prison
Only at nightfall,
aethereal rumours
Revive for a moment a broken
Coriolanus
Da
Damyata:
The boat responded
Gaily, to the hand expert with
sail and oar
The sea was calm,
your heart [and there's this
interesting switch of
tense] would have responded
Gaily, when invited,
beating obedient
To controlling hands
Well, "Dayadhvam" is
translated here as "sympathize."
The poem is,
in many ways,
concerned with sympathy as a
central value,
a central action in human life,
and the lines that they
introduce describe the condition
that sympathy would redress or
enter into in some kind of
healing way.
"I have heard the key / turn in
the door once and turn once
only."
Well, Eliot,
when he produced this poem –
not the first version of this
poem in The Criterion,
his own magazine where it first
was published,
but rather when it appeared in
the United States – added
footnotes,
or rather endnotes, to the poem.
And the endnotes we have here
are worth contemplating.
In a sense, Eliot's notes are a
kind of extension of the poem,
part of the poem.
These lines bear the note
"four":
"And below I heard them
nailing shut the door / of the
horrible tower."
[The speaker of those lines
that Eliot is alluding to,
half-quoting,
is Dante's Count Ugolino in the
thirty-third canto of The
Inferno.]
The traitor Ugolino tells Dante
that his enemies imprisoned him
and his children in a tower to
die of starvation.
And of course,
Ugolino would eat his children.
Eliot continues.
He gives us that little
fragment from Dante,
and then he says:
"Also,
F.H.
Bradley, Appearance and
Reality, p.
346.
[When he writes like that,
it's like wearing that
waistcoat.
It's a kind of pose,
in this case the pose of a
scholar-pedant.
Bradley says:]
'My external sensations are no
less private to myself than are
my thoughts or my feelings.
In either case my experience
falls within my own circle,
a circle closed on the outside;
and, with all its elements
alike, every sphere is opaque to
the others which surround it....
In brief, regarded as an
existence which appears in a
soul, the whole world for each
is peculiar and private to that
soul.'"
Eliot worked on Bradley for his
thesis.
"The whole world for each is
peculiar and private to that
soul."
Well, I don't know that there
is any key to The Waste
Land, but if there is a key
to The Waste Land,
it's this key in these lines,
which lead us to Bradley and
Bradley's view of what
consciousness is like.
Consciousness is a condition in
which we are locked into our
own, I think,
linguistic representations of
reality without a common
language to share them.
How can a common world be
created out of radically private
experience?
Well, this is,
I think, the central question
that The Waste Land is
meditating on,
responding to.
It's one of the central
questions in modern poetry.
We won't get too far in the
poem today.
We'll have to conclude our
discussion on Monday,
but let's look at the beginning
together simply to recall how
this poetry operates and make
some preliminary observations.
This section,
the first section,
is called "The Burial of the
Dead" and refers to the ritual
in the Anglican Church as
described in the Book of
Common Prayer.
April is the cruelest
month, breeding
Lilacs out of the dead land,
mixing
Memory and desire, stirring
Dull roots with spring rain.
Winter kept us warm, covering
Earth in forgetful snow, feeding
A little life with dried tubers.
Summer surprised us,
coming over the Starnbergersee
With a shower of rain;
we stopped in the colonnade,
And went on in sunlight,
into the Hofgarten,
And drank coffee,
and talked for an hour.
Bin gar keine Russin,
stamm' aus Litauen,
echt deutsch.
And when we were children,
staying at the arch-duke's,
My cousin's,
he took me out on a sled,
And I was frightened.
He said, Marie,
Marie, hold on tight.
And down we went.
In the mountains,
there you feel free.
I read, much of the night,
and go south in the
winter.
It's extraordinary poetry.
And one of the ways in which it
is extraordinary is the
modulations, and where do we
pinpoint the turning points
between the initial,
vatic, general voice of the
poem and then that extremely
personalized first person,
who will be Marie,
named that way through that
memory.
How do we get from "April is
the cruelest month" to "I read,
much of the night,
and go south in the winter"?
Somehow there is a variety,
I think, a range of voices
here.
And how Eliot moves from the
one to the other is a question
for us as readers.
I think it also raises,
again, this central problem
that the poem is concerned with.
And that is,
what is the relationship,
how do we articulate the
relationship between the general
and the particular,
between experience that is
generalizable and that which is
almost irreducibly private?
"April is the cruelest month":
those wonderful lines we all
know.
Well, the poem begins with
allusion, which it hardly even
needs to press to "Whan that
Aprill,
with his shoures soote," the
first line of The Canterbury
Tales.
It evokes too,
probably, Whitman's "When
Lilacs Last in the Dooryard
Bloomed," another April elegy.
The poem begins by talking
about the pain of awakened
desire, begins talking about the
risk that comes with beginning
and desiring –
Prufrock's themes.
Here they are, writ large.
Desire, it seems,
is painful because it breaks
things open that are closed and
shut.
It's also, it seems,
unsatisfiable.
All of these are,
to a degree,
conventional Romantic
topoi,
motifs.
Where exactly does the poem
modulate into personal memory?
Well, maybe somewhere in that
eighth line, "Summer surprised
us.
.
."
It started out looking and
feeling a lot like "Winter kept
us warm," but now the memory
will become highly
particularized through
quotation,
incidentally as your note will
explain.
The poem really moves into a
kind of opaque set of personal
associations:
"…when we were children,
staying at the arch-duke's,"
and so on;
"…he took me out on a sled."
These associations are
meaningful and resonant and
representative,
I think, to the extent that
they have a generic quality.
That is, it's not so much that
they are our memories,
but they're like memories.
They're like personal memories,
and they're like personal
memories in the difficulty of
translating and sharing them.
Marie has a kind of exemplary
privacy about her and her
memories and her sense of
frustrated desire and longing.
There is more that's important
about this first of The Waste
Land's speakers.
Well, "Bin gar keine Russin" is
translated for us down below as,
"I'm not a Russian woman at
all;
I come from Lithuania,
a true German."
Whoever is saying that exactly,
whether it's Marie or someone
else, seems to be speaking of a
kind of hybrid identity,
a kind of mongrel or
deracinated identity.
The condition of locked-in
sensibility and difficult
private emotion is,
from the very beginning of the
poem,
associated with metropolitan
culture, a culture where there
are many languages,
speakers from many places.
And, well, a culture where
there are, as it were,
a kind of cacophony of
languages untranslated,
existing and competing
side-by-side.
This is a kind of linguistic
environment that The Waste
Land is made out of and is
also in many ways about and is
the real medium of experience in
the poem.
Well, let me stop here.
And we'll go on trying to make
sense of this great modern poem
on Monday.